( music playing )
Marques: Today I'm going to
talk with Rik Cordero,
a filmmaker who's directed
music videos
with retro aesthetics
for artists like Nas,
Q-Tip, and The Roots.
Rik is here
to help me compare
the analog look
of digital cameras
versus the look of
the original JVC camcorder.
So, this is it.
What I was using
when I was making
these music videos
was the Panasonic HVX--
something that bridged
the gap between consumer
and professional equipment,
and it had this lived-in look.
Great, let's see
if we can put it together.
( music playing )
- This is now adapted.
- It is.
- What I have here today
is that first JVC camera.
- Oh, my God.
I'm really excited
to see what it looks like
next to this thing.
Who's gonna carry
the lighter camera?
That's the question.
- I got this one.
- Thanks.
( muttering )
The only bummer
was not having a screen
- to see anything.
- Yeah.
Now that we've shot with this,
we should switch over
- and see what
the Panasonic system's like.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- How was that?
- Pretty good.
It was framed pretty well,
and I could see it.
When you have the viewfinder,
you feel more confident
in your shots.
Marques: Yeah.
All right, well, let's look
at them side by side.
All right,
so let's check out the JVC.
- ( whirring )
- I love that motorized
sound that it makes.
- That's a long sound.
- It is.
- I'm not even gonna lie.
- You ever see--
- You ever see "RoboCop"?
- No.
Cordero:
They recorded the sounds of,
like, VCRs and VHS camcorders
as the sounds
of when RoboCop walked.
( whirring )
Thank you for your cooperation.
Good night.
( whirring )
That actually makes
a lot of sense.
- Almost everything that's
in highlight is blown out.
- Yeah.
- Uh, not as wide as I thought.
- There you go. There you go.
We're seeing the disadvantage
of not having a viewfinder.
- Yeah. It looks like
found footage.
- Yeah.
We were going for that look.
So, this is really
taking me back.
I was filming VHS movies
when I was 13 years old.
Nothing was perfect, and that's
what made it feel real.
You can add
all the after effects,
plug-ins you want,
and you're not gonna achieve
what's happening here.
Marques: Not something that
could easily be replicated.
- Rik: No.
- Next step is to check out
what the Panasonic system
kicked up. Pause this.
Rik: So we'll play
the first clip. All right.
The framing's
instantly way better,
much more dynamic range,
and, yeah,
colors look way better.
The thing I like is
that you still have this
filmic look to it.
It's a look
that I think really advanced
the look of VHS.
If I were to pick
between these two rigs,
I would still pick this one,
even though it's
a little more taxing
to set up and carry.
But at the end of the day,
this is the grandaddy
of it all.
Rik: Yeah, that's the one
that kicked off everything.